what's up guys it's John Wilde here
editor of GQ magazine
I'm gonna show you all the crazy weird
sexy cool stuff here at the New York
Auto Show let's check it out I'll be
really quick and gentle I promise all
right so I'm in the Genesis New York
concept this thing is astounding
definitely the most popular car you got
to see the interior on this thing
check out this it looks like cloth it's
actually a stainless steel mesh and this
is one giant screen where you've got the
tech ometer over here for the engine
everything else feels like you're on the
Starship Enterprise super futuristic
super cool new Maserati Levante SUV twin
turbo power and Italian style case
you've got a family but you've still got
Briones suitcase whoo right everybody
meets the mazda mx5 retractable fastback
Miata nailed it this has a very cool
trick check it out the entire top pops
down everything folds back it all comes
together and then you have glorious
sunlight it's amazing and stunning and
beautiful this is the Koenigsegg Raj era
1,500 horsepower top speed of about 250
miles an hour two million dollars and
it's a hybrid you're saving the earth
1969 Nissan Skyline 2000 GTR the first
one the newest Nissan GTR faster more
orange really beautiful
howdy r8 v10 here maybe one of the
coolest colors of the show good wood
green
welcome to the Spiker c8 probably a tour
this thing is beautiful and it's even
more beautiful on the inside you gotta
check this out it's insane
each one of those switches costs $50
each I don't know how to count very well
but there's a bunch of them